[Musique]
nous sommes à denain ville est l'un des
hameaux de da dont vie et cet endroit
est lié un homme extraordinaire qui aura
marqué son temps mais aussi d'histoire
il s'agit d'henri louis duhamel
dumonceau un scientifique de xviiie
siècle qui a vécu ici au château de
denain villiers classé monument
historique le château est habité tout ne
se visite pas mais nous allons pouvoir
en découvrir une partie qui fait moi
[Musique]
notre guide c'est l'un des propriétaires
du château l'idée de pelé bonjour
bonjour vous possédez avec votre soeur
sylviane de tori cette bâtisse elle date
de quand alors la maison a été
construite entre 1600 et 1628 les deux
pur style louis xiii et elle est telle
qu'elle était au moment de sa
construction
quand vous avez récupéré le château il
restait quoi alors le canton a repris
cette maison elle était entièrement en
ruines c'était une cour fermée il y
avait trois bâtiments que
malheureusement on n'a pas pu conserver
et donc qui ont été
démolis et il reste les communs d'un
côté et la maison principale de l'eau
[Musique]
d alors nous sommes ici dans le grand
salon qui est une pièce décorée de
boiseries en chêne massif
comme il y en a dans toutes les pièces
de la maison elles sont soit de couleur
naturelle comme ici ou dans la
bibliothèque soit de couleurs peintes
comme dans la chambre près de la
chapelle il ya des choses assez
particulière dans ce château et
notamment la chapelle racontez nous
alors il ya la chapelle qui a été
consacrée en 1628 et qui est telle
qu'elle était au moment de sa
construction avec tous les ornements les
décorations il ya aussi
dans la bibliothèque un cadran solaire
particulier qui s'appelle une méridienne
et il ya dans la chambre de la chapelle
un thermomètre est un baromètre qui date
de 1701 et qui était utilisé par henri
louis duhamel dumonceau pour faire des
relevés météo duhamel du manceau qui
était un grand savant du xviiie siècle
qu'on va en apprendre un peu plus sur
lui dans la prochaine étape de la ville
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le laboratoire dans
louis duhamel dumonceau laboratoire que
vous avez transformé en petit musée qui
était cet homme henri louis est né en
1710 les morts en 1782 et il a vécu
l'essentiel de sa vie à deux ne liez et
il a fait de nombreuses découvertes
fondamentales
il a inventé la météorologie nationale
il a inventé la seule montrer annales
dans l'agriculture il a mis au point le
premier silo de séchage des grains par
air chaud ce silo à grains en quoi il
était révolutionnaire pour l'époque
alors avant on mettait les grains qui
étaient récoltées directement dans les
greniers il était humide et donc pendant
l'hiver il pourrait c'est avec ce moulin
le grain était séché et donc dans les
greniers il ne pourrisse est pas et les
les agriculteurs pouvaient donc se
nourrir pendant tout l'hiver et ressemer
le grain pour le printemps dont le
s'améliorer grandement leur vie
[Musique]
nous sommes dans le parc du château de
denain villiers mais à l'époque henri à
louis duhamel du manceau n'avait pas du
tout cette vue non effectivement à
l'époque c'était un jardin à la
française mais comme la maison il a été
malheureusement à l'abandon et on essaye
de le récupérer petit à petit de duhamel
dumonceau il reste presque rien trois ou
quatre arbres en particulier des cèdres
est un sel kova qui datent de cette
époque là est ce qu'on peut dire que
finalement bout de toutes ces années
henri-louis duhamel du monceau est
devenu un membre de votre famille oui on
peut dire ça on peut dire qu'il est
devenu un lieu grand oncle voilà à force
de parler de lui à force à force de
parler de lui à force d'avoir découvert
ce qu'il a fait
toutes les innovations et surtout
d'avoir contribué à au développement de
l'économie locale merci olivier de pelé
de nous avoir ouvert chez vous ce
château de 2,9 y y et vous envoie voilà
donc pour cette découverte loire et n le
bastion d'henri viii duhamel dumonceau
le château de denain vie et peut être
visitée sur demande près de 500
personnes y viennent chaque année